if you're a product manager you need to
know exactly who your customers are what
they need and how they engage in your
product the key to obtaining this
information is user research
in this course i'll show you how to
apply user research to every stage of
the product life cycle to ensure the
success of your product in your team
let's use a research it's a process for
learning more about your customer by
going out and talking to them you can
learn really important things like what
your customers are actually doing and
thinking what feedback they have about
your product ideas and how they interact
with the design that you and your team
create it's like a secret weapon that
you use regularly to give you a sneak
peek into what's really going to happen
when you launch preventing hours of
heartache over unnecessary features and
poor design and it's so easy to do i
think everyone can learn it and
integrate it into their process to
create those once-in-a-lifetime products
that customers absolutely can't get
enough of i'll help you understand what
user research methods are out there when
to use them and how to use them
we'll deep dive into three key methods
rapid experimentation moderated and
unmoderated testing learning the skills
for each method so you can go out there
and do it yourself or support your team
in gathering data i am really passionate
about user research and i am thrilled to
share with you all the insider tips and
tricks for how to do a great job at all
aspects of testing from planning your
tests to recruiting subjects to
analyzing your data
see you in class